[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
for those of you that don't know me i'm
adam's illegitimate son so uh
yeah we have the same the same vibe
right i i guess i don't know
weren't we talking about how jimmy
kimmel said i look like pete sampras but
with down syndrome
and i was like all right now that's my
new thing and then sam you look like me
with down syndrome were we i was hoping
like michael phelps with down syndrome
but
i'll take i'll take corolla
well i'm i'm saying
it's not enough that you look like
somebody you need to look like a down
syndrome version
i think it was tough i just look like
down syndrome
just down syndrome
she's a real bummer
and then haley joel osment looks like
you with down syndrome so
yeah
i look like you're a handler i'm like
he's very functional
bro
crocs is new york this guy knows new
york
he's just a kid from far rocks
he's not even he can't even see new york
in four rockwell didn't even know 9 11
happened it was going about that
day they even know that it happened they
didn't even know they didn't know until
like two days later they're like
you were right there for 9 11.
new yorkers son i was there you were a
new yorker
i was a new yorker you you were a new
yorker and you what were you doing
planning it
son of a [ __ ]
what were you doing back then
[ __ ]
did you take that day off school so you
could celebrate
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
disney world
i just feel like i'm going with the only
suggestion i can hear you know
there might have been a better one
disney world it's a great place to meet
kids right
does paul like me paul who doesn't like
who doesn't like joe list
a lot of people in the comments section
right now
the content
it doesn't matter how many people i'm
like everyone's favorite comedians
favorite comedian they don't buy it
louie can go on this guy they're like
[ __ ] ari [ __ ] this guy de paulo they do
it for attention they do it for
attention but half of them are doing
hate mcdonald they're like he's
something's up this guy's paying normal
like what do you want me to do
they hate me it's uh i'm telling you
it's a do it for it you can't read the
comments sometimes i think they did
negativities like uh because it it makes
you more visible in the comments yeah
it's fun too to shut up bar talk it's
just at the bar yeah this is just that
it's on print and it feels bad but it's
just the same blah [ __ ] that guy yeah
and then if you go like really why [ __ ]
that guy i don't know i don't know i
actually kind of like him yeah [ __ ] him
i don't know for right now [ __ ] him i
think it's my face i think i've told you
this story before it's i was opening for
dane 2004 dane cook and this is when
dane was about to really break but was
selling out every club show and this is
in boston where he broke first yeah so
he was about to become like
stratospheric and every show sold adding
shows and i was opening
and i was killing i was 22 and a guy
this is in boston he was stage left and
he stood up in middle of my set and he
goes
this guy's a [ __ ] nerd
in the middle of my set and i went what
the hell
and then nobody said anything and he sat
down
and i just went that was crazy whatever
and i kept doing instead i was doing
well and he stood up a second time he
goes
hey seriously
he's a [ __ ] nerd
and i think people don't like my face
what is this
lgbtqip2sa is this one of elon musk's
new kids names what is this
lesbian gay by okay so lgbtqq
ip2 saa stands for lesbian gay bisexual
transgender questioning queer intersex
pansexual two-spirit androgynous and
asexual two-spirit is a term used by
some indigenous north americans to
describe those who fulfill a traditional
third gender ceremonial role the local
democracy reporting service said this is
what the guy maxie was remember we had
we had a guest on the show max he was uh
he's like o'hare and makeup guy that i
know i hear he said he's like uh he's a
two spirit he's a two-spirit indigenous
spirit yeah he's a two-speed he doesn't
know what he is he said every day i wake
up and i'm a different one of the
letters whoa oh man that's gotta be all
that's so exhausting yeah i just you
know jerk off to whatever gets me going
that day it's me dude yeah whether it's
a relative or or or a hobo what do you
know that's how i feel it's like
sometimes i'm watching like you know
like whatever like lesbian porn
sometimes i'm watching porn that looks
like my wife and then the other day i
was i jerked off to wade boggs because i
was just
i was just i was just reminiscing about
the good old yankee days when he was
riding around the horse and i just he
was turning me on his bound you know his
butt bouncing her up in those pin
stripes i missed baseball yeah yeah well
it's trying to skew younger and i've
jerked off to your wife as well so yeah
it's all full circle dude a guy in
philadelphia just got his skull
fractured by a group of teenagers jumped
him what would you do dude four 13 year
olds come up to try to [ __ ] you up first
off unlike these guys who are afraid to
be racist i'm on guard when i see them
i walk by like this
and i'm prepared
you're fully locked in i literally
yeah
keep my feet square and walk past him
like that
what else could you do i think i'm gonna
get knocked out
dude he got his skull fractured they had
to take didn't they take a piece of his
skull out
he was around where the hell were you
dude that was in your [ __ ] neck of
the woods
you and your buddies should get together
you and your buddies should form a i
don't know
mom
if you're walking down the street you've
been getting crushed with cnn msnbc
you're like i'm not gonna even worry
about that that's what happened walk
with my hands straight down and have a
nice dirt
hey guys look at this i'm doing well
right now i'm not worried at all
just got crushed yeah you want to hear
another old white guy complaint what
when did shoplifting become totally okay
[Laughter]
every time i go dude
i'm mad i wanted to duane read today
[ __ ] pistachios are behind a locked
case oh dude everything's locked it's
annoying you gotta [ __ ] hit a button
and have some guy walk down and be like
could i get a
fungal cream
yeah the fungal cream i could see kevin
you gotta lock that up dude yeah that's
some that's life-saving technology
pistachios is like bro
john wayne gacy otherwise known as tim
dillon don't they look alike
[Applause]
they really do look alike
and not just in personality you know
real quick just want to clarify that
this is best of comedians are currently
in new york i know on part one there
were a lot of comments being like
where's tim dillon mark norman's not
from new york he's from louisiana i just
want to clarify this is comedian's
currently in new york but we're making a
part three so if you think tim should be
in part three or other comedians from
new york let me know in the comments be
like i think tim should be in part three
or other comedians from new york and if
there's a lot of those then they will be
included all right back to the video
that [ __ ] thumbnail you can't not
click on it you see that mug on that
thumbnail
someone pointed out uh oh time to suck
mark off
he was very clear about what the beep
means
[Laughter]
somebody pointed out after the fact that
i did not realize this at all they were
like he's dressed exactly like ali wong
without even realizing it i completely
stole i'm talking about people stealing
from me i completely stole her whole
vibe and the pregnancy and then the
stomach yeah
i'm embracing yes
absolutely look at you no more features
in bread you're not all [ __ ] weird no
bro i'm primal i'm mesopotamian
mesopotamia prime minister no that's not
inbred that's pure you're bonobo
you're one of them chimpanzees everybody
[ __ ] your own family that's what it is
you're a chimpanzee i'm primal
no you're scottish bro you're big you
bang your cousin i don't bang my cousins
how close in your family do you think of
relative [ __ ] be completely honest you
got first cousins that [ __ ] that's not
even a question definitely
you have siblings my mom told me she
fingered her cousin
he has gotten a lot better wants me to
say he's gotten a lot better falls but
he
happens
i haven't had a panic attack in years
and i would argue recently you've had
more anxiety than me i would say in the
last six months do you think so
absolutely
wow yeah absolutely a good thing for you
to say in front of the friends if you
haven't said that
well don't you've
i'm not so anxious now you've ma you've
got this oh i'm just sitting there look
at this he's 100 right he has been more
of like a calming he's been a calming
influence what don't be ashamed of your
anxiety what are you ashamed of i'm not
ashamed i'm just saying i've improved
you want it acknowledged that you've
improved of course that makes sense
that's anxiety
yeah they tell them not as anxious
anymore ego that's the ego not anxiety
yes no you of course he has he has grown
up a lot too as a person
the first time i was having trouble
swallowing you you're come yeah
but then i i added more
to my diet there you know thinning
you know tea tree oil i like the way
phrase that we toured together so he's
it's [ __ ] big movie star now yeah i
was like oh really he's co-headlined you
and louis
you guys tour together you're doing like
uh we were on tour together
double-headed monster thing where are we
not on tour yeah kardashian hey
that's a fun one all right all right
well uh
you know pete davidson's in there now
which is impressive because hey that's a
comedian and he's gentrifying her vagina
which is uh
you know
it's usually a lot of black in there and
you know a whitey came in and uh i had
to
had to clean up the neighborhood you
know
that's exciting
yeah
kardashians are fun there's like eight
of them i like them they're they're
they're fun they're [ __ ] they have
fake ass
the hotel room you guys are basically
i was just about to ask you you have no
idea what's been going on in here i can
tell i walked in when i walked in here
jesus i got like hit with an
overwhelming afterglow just imagine what
i've been doing i walked in an absolute
sexual aftermath
big
face in their butt just
suckling dude you're suckling at the
troll dude
if you ever lay horizontal and just get
up in the trunk
i run from there
i get in the bathroom and get naked
i'm a big fan of the shoot of top button
undone tie a little loose yeah you got
it from otherwise you feel like from the
top of the day i mean oh 100 percent i
leave the house on button yeah yeah yeah
yeah let you know you're serious but you
like the parties yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] casual yeah i definitely look at
a wedding like the guy that's got a bag
on him
yeah and a two dollar bill to do that to
that bag with i undoubtedly look like
that guy yeah at the wedding what do you
usually do at a wedding um
coke
i have like a full day's worth of
activities and it's like if you do that
for more than like four weeks you're
just like
[ __ ] tired you can't do it like this
philadelphia i was in my bed
for 12. like i'm just like the show is
at seven
or seven thirty and it's like all right
well i'll get breakfast yeah i wake up
at one p.m i get breakfast at a diner i
go back into my bed until sev until 6
50.
i get there as jp is halfway into a set
i do the first one i lay on the couch
i lay on the couch between eat a chicken
a comedy club chicken tender yeah i'm
like oh i don't want to do this [ __ ]
show this picture of waitress feeding
your grapes
where i wasn't even trying to get [ __ ]
that's when you know i'm depressed
where's the girls that remind them like
you want to come to a bar i'm like a bar
even women you want delivery like i
don't want to get takeout
[Laughter]
no one's policing not like priests come
under fire because they're controlling
all the money if i get a whole parish as
a nun you could probably munch away
pretty much pretty much in peace and you
can munch box yeah i think the latter
slide
yeah as a pre-sucking dick is much more
grave sin or again yeah that getting
puzzled a lot of those dudes have
girlfriends really yeah dude they must
be cool
i actually like those priests they're
pretty they are actually pretty cool
yeah my uh
my bro was working spud man was working
how many confessions can you take before
you try to [ __ ]
the lady came in and confessed to some
wild [ __ ] i'd be like
mash up against the screen be like
sliding it open what
mouse my pants
what the [ __ ] is that lady
this ain't a [ __ ] escape room what's
wrong with
you got [ __ ] jigsaw sitting in the
second row
mouse in your picture
wait was that a comment on my penis size
it's more of a chipmunk to be honest
with you
that's hardly none of your business
young lady
all right go ahead
aliens that's what i'm talking about
i mean i think we do need to improve the
southern border a little bit to be
honest with you
like illegal aliens you know
it's [ __ ] staring at me like i'm
santa claus i don't know
good looking kid though i'll tell you
that
no mouse in those pants huh
i got this big gig because seinfeld
shouted me out and once seinfeld i was
at the mets game he shouted you out at
that was crazy he stands wow how crazy
is that i was at the freaking mets game
that he have you told the story about
how he doesn't call you anymore oh yeah
yeah
we did it we did it on uh we did i i
have a for the 25 members at patreon.com
christy comedy we do a thing called the
chris and eddie show i call edibles
eddies where i take inedible with
homeless pimp and then they wait 30
minutes and then i do the show on
eddie's christian eddie show and i told
the story i started reading texts on the
patreon from seinfeld
[Laughter]
oh my god that's wild that's wild dude
and i was like oh boy so pimp was like
put it at the 25 level that's how we
thought of the idea because i was like
we got to put it out right he was like
yeah but dude you started reading
seinfeld texts oh and i was like what do
we do he's like what if he put at the 25
dollar level i was like all right yeah
let's give her a name and he was like
well you took edibles i was like uh the
christianity show oh
you get to the 30 it's cosby text oh
yeah yeah dude oh yeah i'll start yeah
absolutely yeah so you know it's crazy
he's shouting me out whatever and it
didn't do [ __ ] for my career i thought
oh i'll be selling out the next day
didn't make a blip yeah i mean it was
good for me and my mom fingered herself
and all that but other than that it was
hey mom oh sorry
she knows she's done it and uh yeah so
uh what was i saying sorry your mom's
distracting me
yeah yeah yeah so but what it did do was
these corporates hit me up like who's
this whiz kid that seinfeld's talking
about you know so i got hired by all
these giant pharmaceuticals
money money money money money money was
a good year yeah and i bombed every
single one of them but this one in
particular they bought me a tuxedo they
got me a limo to philadelphia in this
beautiful ballroom it was a drug company
it was like the the oscars for a drugs
right for like pills and pfizer and all
this [ __ ] and it was a three hour thing
i was supposed to do 15 minutes up top
and actually you know jimmy kimlin do
the awards show sure ellen degeneres
whatever it was
billy crystal
so i bombed the first 15 minutes this is
like the biggest gig of my life how many
people know what would you say roughly
huh how many people i don't know 600 in
a ballroom tuxedo it's like oh that's
the guy who owns routers and that's the
guy who invented the iphone harvey
weinstein yeah all those guys were there
the whole thing yeah al gore it was
crazy oh my god i know and so i got to
do all the you know the best uh
antidepressant goes to
do to die you know all the drugs that
sound like black women's names and
so
i'm in the tuxedo i go up they hate me
already i gotta eat dinner with them too
and then they go mark norman the host
and i go up there butt up uh there's a
big podium and everything and the first
15 minutes i die zero zero and i'm doing
tonight's show like
material great if you're if you have
smart to do his a stuff it's killer
shots oh thanks yeah and obviously clean
and all that so i was like man this is a
tough group but i did one joke about a
vibrator but it's very clean it's just i
mentioned the word vibrator once i see a
woman get up in the back uh
she walks out i go oh whatever she's
probably menstruating or miscarriaging
whatever it is and then i go back uh you
know to my act blah blah blah bombing
whatever then we go into the awards show
and i'm bringing up oh this guy won he
comes up says his little thing with the
trophy i make fun of him and then they
didn't like that so
at one point somebody's giving a speech
and i have to i have a moment off to the
side and this lady in the headset's like
get over here get over it she's like you
pissed off the ceo's wife she's furious
she's chewing him out in the lobby uh i
don't know what's going gonna happen but
it ain't pretty and she's kind of crying
a little bit i'm like what is going on
oh i go back up there i'm like hey the
award for uh the best diarrhea pill goes
to this guy so he comes out and then
they bring me back
you're fired he's pissed the co is
yelling at me he's like how could you
say that my wife is furious you're such
a misogynist i'm like what are you
talking about this is all tonight show
stuff yeah and he i was like i hope for
seinfeld he's like you're a disgrace you
should be ashamed of yourself they fired
me they made me return the tuxedo they
gave the stack of cards to some random
indian guy and he had to host the rest
and they sent me home what did you get
paid i had to fight for it but i got
like half the money shout out judy
marmel
so we were doing that exact same thing
we were on a
only no not only um free ones
doc i forget what it was there was like
a cam girl thing sure yeah where you
could like chat to them and my friend
was just saying the worst [ __ ] he could
think of yeah
like all that and then the next day me
and my friend jared were up in my room
we were playing grand theft auto
and uh
didn't realize my dad was standing there
and we were just talking about
you're reciting what my friend was
saying oh so like my dad was just
outside the door and it was like oh yeah
i want to see [ __ ] blood all over
that dildo and you pull it out of my
head like all this [ __ ] my dad's like
open the door was like hey
what's going on here
nothing dad it was from a porn website
oh man
start crying you punish you no
what are you saying he knew not to
punish me there sure yeah it's weird to
see the other side
you also just want to get the right type
of opener too yeah like sometimes a club
like if it's funny when people don't
really understand how to book things and
it's like oh i know who you'll like so
you're going to love your opener he's
he's exactly like you right he's some
fat guy that talks about his little dick
just you know less accomplished with
less good jokes you know what i mean and
it's just like it's like he's a cool guy
i like him and i see what he he might
even be me ten years ago yeah i mean yes
but i don't want me 10 years ago opening
for me you know i want like a like a
like a lesbian housewife someone who i
have nothing in common around you know
what i mean like someone who has a
completely different perspective on
things so so it's like when you bring
your friend and it's just like you know
it's just fun to have you guarantee you
know what you're walking into you know
you get you you need a different opener
i i've had that two-hour show up and
it's like a tall dude with one eyebrow
yeah he's doing dead baby jokes like
come on
and it's like just it's just they're
just watching a worse version of you
right you know what i mean where it's
like that's not how you want to get like
if you were about to eat a like a
perfect like you know perfectly cooked
rare steak you wouldn't want somebody
just throwing you some [ __ ]
steakhouse
deviled egg i'll have a scallop you know
what i mean like you know you you don't
want a shittier so anyway and not only
is it a shittier version but they're
stepping on all your processes
so you're like [ __ ] yeah now i can't do
mine because it looks shitty tacked on
doesn't mean we don't think they're
funny too it's just you don't want them
on your show
and that's why that's the lessons you
learn when you start headlining and you
look back kind of what you said with the
green room i owe so much to bobby kelly
because the fact that he had some little
fat kid doing just shitty fat jokes in
his
fat jokes
it's like i don't like i'm gonna kiss
him on the lips dude i could say the
same about david tell 100 no literally
when you said like you just want a
shittier version opening the first thing
i said i was like i used to open for
david
both of us
we were both just worst versions of the
guys that brought us on so they're
better people than us yeah oh yeah i can
say the same thing about amy schumer
emotions
emotions i don't have those all right
come on
give me something i can use there please
helen keller holy [ __ ]
wow
wow
that is a special lady there uh
helen keller
deaf blind dumb right what is dumb you
always hear that now it's like deaf
blind and dumb what the [ __ ] is dumb i
mean
why do they always have dumb with those
i mean i figured they were dumb they're
[ __ ] deaf and blind
i can't read or
watch tv and [ __ ] so uh how're they
gonna get the new how do blind people
and deaf people get the news
what do you do
all right yeah
you got braille i guess but you can't
really tell them how to use it i guess
yeah
that's a tough one not to mention the
ass wiping that's the whole thing there
too but we'll get to that later all
right well this uh this took a turn my
dad was a sanitation man okay classic
new staten island job yes it is good
bennies yes nice yes growing up he had a
bunch of jobs i don't mean that
toby cut this
i don't need joey wrench coming in
just let's unplug these mic
this guy's wearing a wire every time i
see a tell e uh i i know him for years
but i don't know him very very well like
anybody else and he always just assumed
because i'm like i'm half italian but
i'm from staten island my name is sal
everyone always just stereotypes me
right away yeah he always is like every
time he digs i just want to talk
sopranos
he's like they're making a sopranos
movie you should audition
or he'll be like oh yeah and he'll just
ask me mafia questions and i'm like man
i just scratched a little more of the
surface with me david please i'm not
that god i also love when he thinks you
need to play goon number three in the
sopranos movie
also despite the garden later
you can't do it for your penny vodka
recipe
despite that too sometimes like he calls
me saul
i'm saul the mafia guy to him i guess
i don't know i never have the heart to
correct him
yeah with guys like that you're like oh
okay i'm sorry i mean yeah if i'm in
front of him if he's near me and
someone's like hey i'm bill i'm like hey
soul volcano
i'm sure there's you know that was a
bomb but i'm sure some of the other ones
were great nah they're all pretty bad i
i did one there's another one so guys
saw me the seller a hedge fund guy goes
i'll give you five this is six years i
give you five grand to roast my company
i get five grands the most money i've
ever seen in my life he's like come up
to westchester i go to this golf course
it's ferraris and bugattis it's the
richest people on the planet and i get
there and he gave me a cheat sheet like
a rap sheet of all the dirt on everybody
so i go there he's smoking a big cigar
he's got a scotch he's like this hot guy
with slicked back hair and he goes all
right you're on i go up white tablecloth
everybody's loaded
families moms dads the whole thing the
whole company is there and i go hey
richie and he goes uh i go we all know
you're gay his wife's like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
you were gay so they're fighting i was
like oh that's a bomb hey uh hey reggie
yeah yeah hey we all know you're a coke
and he's like shut the [ __ ] up
everything's backfiring nothing's
working hey uh sid we all know you're
cheating on your wife she's like i knew
it the [ __ ] plate flips over
dying the guy in the back's going
so then i go into my act which they you
know they're like hey what's the deal
with uber yeah they already hate me you
know yeah and i could see waiters like
oh this is bad so i ended up doing like
12 minutes supposed to do an hour and he
cut the mic he pushed me off and he
chewed me out on the deck outside but
you got the five grand i got the five
great that's all that matters dude you
get the five grand you have to have this
above look of like these these were
these [ __ ] knuckleheads want yeah and
feed it to them but if you really
believe yeah you're gonna get caught in
all kinds of problems yeah cause you're
just gonna answer what you really think
god bless you [ __ ] movie movie star
sneeze
bottle it bottle it
put it in a bottle yeah that was a fake
sneeze yeah i'm good i have an actor i'm
auditioning for my next role a guy with
allergies
wasn't even real yeah but they're
hypocrites though they don't i don't
know a lot of the guys at the top i
don't know if they fully believe that
there's plenty of guys that don't yeah
and they [ __ ] everything that moves and
they do whatever you know yeah that's me
mm-hmm yeah
the one that moves
like anything that moves so you're gonna
leave your wife now like what's the deal
what do you do from here now that you're
i don't have it in me to leave her but
i'm like i'm hoping for a death any kind
of
buying their flights
car rides
i'm encouraging her not to wear a seat
she's just sending her to the store at
three in the morning after you read the
new york post like it's a funny bit is
like i would never i wouldn't ever kill
my wife but i do hope she does
you just keep putting her in dangerous
situations yeah just hope it's just i
would never do anything but
i do hope i got you a cruise it's in
september in the caribbean
honey meet me at 4 00 a.m in the bronx
no no don't take an uber we can't afford
it no it's fine trust me they just sit
there and cross your fingers
i was just gonna oh [ __ ] oh oh seguro
you know with the personal trainer he
does the piano lessons he plays with his
kids he does four podcasts then he gets
in a pj and goes to denver and does an
arena and then he writes a book yeah he
wrote a [ __ ] book and i'm like i get
it you're the man
he makes millions and millions of
dollars a year he's hilarious he's
awesome cool guy
i'd rather have a little edge yeah i'd
rather part i'd rather have some
memories some crazy stories i'd rather
have a hangover every now and then and
eat some chicken fingers
and you know [ __ ] my girl in the
bathroom or the green room yeah
is that doing that oh yeah you [ __ ] her
in the green room bathroom sure
you don't have a pre-show ritual
yeah i
i didn't realize
what uh
degenerate
what you were i had no clue i'm a
fun-loving guy no no you're you're
fun-loving and you're a guy
yeah
you have these insane i'm stumbling
across this youtube video we were
talking about having sex with this
homeless girl yeah that's quite a thing
how yeah wow
she didn't tell me she was homeless till
uh
far in okay but basically uh you know
lovely lady and i took i was broke i was
an open micro in new york this is years
and years ago and uh i took her to this
bar called alligator lounge where you
get a free pizza with every drink i said
williamsburg yeah yeah there's one on uh
houston no 14th okay yeah crocodile
lounge is two
and i i didn't have any money so i was
like i'll get her a drink and a pizza
and she wolfed that [ __ ] pizza down
she was pounding booze i mean she ate
must eaten three pizzas we jump in a cab
and she tells the cabbie where to go
we're making out in the cab she smelled
terrible and uh we go all the way up to
way out brooklyn we get to some giant
building and it's like a government
building yeah and she snuck me in and i
could hear women crying and there was
[ __ ] everywhere and babies screaming and
that's when i got hard
yeah and so she was staying basically in
a woman's shelter she was a drug addict
and a whole thing and it was great it
was great like hobo box car sex
you had sex in the women's shelter yes
were you even allowed in the woods no
no no way but i had to pee at one point
she was like you can't go out there
they'll they'll kill you you know you go
up there you're not allowed to be here
so i had to sneak into the women's
bathroom and then women are coming in
and like brushing their teeth and [ __ ]
so i had to like tuck my feet up you
know on the stall
it was brutal but i got out of there
and you know she's dead
how did you sneak in in the first place
she got me in she got me in she knew the
guy at the gate and i she put makeup on
me that was no i forgot about that yeah
what yeah that's true yeah yeah tell the
story these women were so beaten and
battered they're not gonna question me
yeah so she amber herded me up and put
some makeup on me and uh i got in there
yeah that's the most insulting part of
this whole thing what that you asked for
a chick yeah
a battered chick
you can't really you know you can't
question that [ __ ] anymore yeah you know
this is before all that yeah i guess
they just didn't they didn't they did oh
that's right now you could sneak into a
woman's shelter no problem yeah oh you
can sneak into the olympics
[Music]
you